مطر وخرسن بسرحوا المعارك الطاحنه
لاستعاده المدينه من قبضه الروس
المنطقه تعج بالالغام
غير بعيد عن هنا ترابط كتيبه جنود
اوكرانيين في الخنادق
والقذائف والطائرات المسيره نهر النيبر
يفصلنا عن العدو
على مقربه من جسر انطونيوسكي على ضفاف
دنيبر ستكون فسحتك قاتله القناصه الروس في
حالات تاهب قصوى في الضفه الاخرى يعلي
الدخان ما يوحي باستهداف القصف الاوكراني
للمواقع الروسيه من بقي من السكان يعاني
قصف الجانبين
في قلب المدينه طابور انتظار ضخم على امل
الحصول على بعض الاغذيه والملابس
هو دافئ
في الخارج مواطنون فقدوا الامل بعد طول
انتظار
الرابعه والنصف لالتحق بالطابور ولم احصل
على شيء لا اعتقد انني سانجح في ذلك اليوم
ايضا
فنن بشكل دائم بوم بوم بوم بشكل يومي
تقريبا بوم بوم بوم اعصابي لم تعد تتحمل
المزيد
بعد انسحابها من خرسون بدات القوات
الروسيه في قصف المدينه بشكل مكثف وبطريقه
عشوائيه
في شهر نوفمبر الماضي كانت هذه الساحه في
قلب مدينه خرسون مركز احتفال الاوكرانيين
بالانتصار على القوات الروسيه
وانسحابها من المدينه الى ضفه الاخرى من
لكن الحقيقه ان 85% من السكان فالرو منها
[موسيقى]
على الجهه الاخرى من نهر دنيبر جزيره
اوستريم منطقه سكنيه تقصف يوميا هي الان
في عيد الاوكرانيين لكن الروسي رابطون على
بعد مئات الامتار
هذه السيده اختارت البقاء
المدفعيه تقصفنا بطريقه وحشيه لا نعلم من
اي اتجاه تاتي صواريخ من لم يغادرهم
الاكثر مقاومه لماذا لم تغادري
اولا لاننا نرفض ذلك وايضا لاننا قومي
[تصفيق]
هذا البرج السكني استهدف في مناسبتي بعض
الشقق لم يهجرها سكانها من بقي منهم
يدردشون امام مدخل البنايه
اين ساذهب هناك خطر سرقه منازلنا وايضا
اعاني من بعض الامراض ولا املك المال
اين ساذهب ومن سياخذني
بعض السكان يتشبثون بحييهم مهما كلفهم ذلك
البعض الاخر اختار المغادره في هذه المحطه
حافله تستعد لمغادره المدينه
نعم
السائق في حاله من التوتر منذ قليل سقطت
قضيه على الحافله
ام وابنتها من حي اوستريف تغادران ايضا
انتظرنا لاخر لحظه على امل تغيير الوضع
لكن لم يعد بوسعنا تحمل لفتره اطول
نحب مدينتنا ونحب منازلنا ونفكر في العوده
لن نغادر ابدا
ستبقى خرسنا انتصارا ساحقا بالنسبه
للاوكرانيين لكن انسحاب الروسي منها لا
يعني بالضروره نهايه الحرب في الجبهه
الجنوبيه من اختار البقاء يدرك ان حياته
في خطر